quand olivier guichard lors d'une
inauguration prétexte rencontre le 23
janvier 98 à sablé le premier magistrat
de la ville il y à là comme un parfum de
passage de témoin pour françois fillon
qui est en quelque sorte
intronisé dauphin du patron des pays de
la loire qu'il est à la fois long et
sans faille le chemin parcouru depuis
son premier mandat de conseiller
municipal sabolien lorsque joël le
theule est décédé en 1981 et que les
habitants fallait convié les élus
appelés sourdines demandé de me
présenter aux élections municipales
je suis tombé des nues j'ai réfléchi 48
heures et j'ai fait un choix qui a
conditionné le reste mon existence en 76
déjà il est attaché parlementaire de
joël le theule
il gravit ensuite rapidement les
échelons de la politique sarthoise et
nationale 80
l'enfant du pays devient au moment de
l'arrivée de mitterrand au pouvoir
le benjamin de l'assemblée nationale à
27 ans avec des idées bien arrêtées
nous avons toujours voulu nous adresser
à toute la france et à toutes ses
composantes et je crois que de ce point
de vue là il est juste de dire que le
gaullisme n'est ni de gauche ni de
droite
92 le député maire de sablé prend
d'assaut la présidence du conseil
général de la sarthe puis dans la foulée
devient en 93 et 95 ministre des
gouvernements balladur et juppé
ce professionnel de la politique n'a
guère eu le temps depuis d'exercer ses
passions la course à pied
l'eau de montagne alpinisme le ski mais
je reconnais qu'avec le temps qui passe
je les performances ne s'améliore pas et
pour cet homme pressé qui s'est lié
d'une amitié indéfectible pour philippe
séguin la politique revient vite à la
une
bouleversement du calendrier électoral a
porté par législatif anticipé n'a pas
encore fini de produire des effets il
est incontestable que si les élections
législatives avaient eu lieu alors date
les choses auraient sans doute été
différent même si les conséquences de
cette dissolution dont on n'a pas fini
par les lui trotte toujours dans la tête
une chose est sûre pour reconquérir le
pouvoir françois fillon n'est pas prêt à
vendre son âme pour des alliances contre
nature